promised to you though that I was going
to show you something called calculator
right not just this multiplying stuff
which is pretty boring to me yours but I
want you to look for this button okay it
is let's see
it's what a left you calculator in the
middle of it once now what I want you to
do is go back to this original
calculation okay
this seven three quarters five and a
half we end up with this to get 42 and
five-eighths okay that's the first step
right literally this is what I type I
type 42 okay then I press the shift
button because I want to make a mixed
numeral not just a regular fraction okay
so shift and then the fraction button
which I think looks like this okay
that'll put a mixed numeral oops that'll
put a mix Nero on your display and
you'll be on the numerator then you
press five because that's what the
numerator is
and then to go down to the denominator
you have to bring it down I think so you
press down and then you can type eight
okay that'll give you the denominator
and then you can press equals
it gives it back to you as an what what
if you got on you got better it should
be giving you an improper fraction right
it's giving you that fish okay watch
this put your calculators down for a
second watch for the magic okay this
button here what is this button okay I
don't know if you know these are these
symbols okay there are three separate
symbols does anyone recognize what the
first symbol is you all know it we're
using it it's mindful slightly to degree
a circle it's a circle a square I've
heard it it's a degreaser
I can't now stay with me I'm not
finished yet the first symbol is degrees
okay
the second see what the third symbol
there are about ways of breaking up
degrees because sometimes you know for
example if you're going very long
distance like on a boat it's not enough
to be one degree accurate you need to
divide it up right
so after degrees just like hours are
broken up into minutes degrees are also
broken up into minutes there are 60
minutes in a degree so you can the
picture how big of degree is it's pretty
small it's a bit right well minute some
are even smaller okay the last
measurement there that one on the end
with the two marks B this is called
minutes what do you think these are
called they're called seconds now by the
way just because you guys know I like
words right the reason why I'm minutes
are called minutes is because they are
my Gooch they're small that's literally
all of eight seconds are called seconds
because they're second by a newt
Division of whatever you're interested
in whether it's time or degrees now
here's where the cookie is now quickly
calculated back up you've got 341 over
eight on there I want you to press this
button it's called the degrees minutes
seconds but I want you to press it just
once
here's what I see it says this 4237 now
I know we're not thinking of angles
again the button you're looking for
looks like this but angles and hours
broken up in exactly the same way you
recognize these numbers right sir in the
future anytime you get a time
measurement okay like this we end up
with a fraction okay simply go to this
degrees minutes seconds button you just
have to press it and just like
converting between decimal and a
fraction this will convert you into well
this is an angle sets degrees but you
can just as easily think of it
hours minutes seconds okay super cool
trick that you can use